with interchange sometimes comes outer
change in the last Jedi the second
installment of the most recent Star Wars
trilogy the villainous kylo Ren
lightsaber slashes his way to a new
position of power within the first order
Supreme Leader snatching the title from
his former mentor Snoke after
assassinating him in his throne room as
a symbolic gesture rejecting snoke's
influence over him well before that ren
smashes his helmet which is particularly
notable given snoke's insult no just a
child
animos the Skywalker saga ending film
the rise of Skywalker sees kylo
exercising his new authority and taking
on a modified version of his old look he
has the helmet rebuilt from its pieces
inspired to do so after meeting Emperor
Palpatine the reworked headgear features
jagged silver bits and red vein like
stripes running across it evidence that
these smashed parts got welded back
together in a not totally precise way
rise of Skywalker director JJ Abrams
said the imperfections are an
intentional example of kinsuka or golden
repair which involves repairing broken
pottery using visible gold seems the
Japanese technique is particularly
appropriate since kylo Ren and Darth
Vader's costumes are based on samurai
garb Abrams told Empire like that
classic Japanese process of taking
ceramics and repairing them as fractured
as Ren is the mask becomes a visual
representation of that there's something
about this that tells his history his
mask doesn't ultimately hide him and his
behavior is revealed kylo Ren actor Adam
driver likewise revealed the reason in a
recent interview with Entertainment
Weekly that the helmet is meant to
reflect kylo Ren's inner conflicts he
said he's a very unformed person which
is exciting to play and to have that be
represented physically in a costume
piece or a lighting choice or in this
case a helmet it's a coming together
he's cherry-picked things he's looked at
through his history and that he's
decided he wants to claim for who he is
so it's a physical representation of how
that character has grown kylo Ren has
certainly evolved over the course of the
current Star Wars trilogy he started an
ambitious temperamental young man who
idolized his grandfather Darth Vader he
killed his own father Han Solo because
he was desperate for power but he
eventually becomes driven more by a
sense of personal value drivers approach
to the character has evolved to chatting
with cinema blend just ahead of the rise
of Skywalker's release driver opened up
about how playing kylo Ren changed for
him from the force awakens to the rise
of Skywalker he said of working with
Abrams who also directed the force
awakens on the new movie there is just a
short hand right away that we didn't
have on force awakens there was no time
wasted of you know does he like me am i
giving him the right
right away we started this one with me
like there is no idea that we can leave
off the table everything that you're
thinking and that I'm thinking we have
to say it and try it because we only
have this opportunity to do it there was
already an immediacy and familiarity
with each other that there was no time
wasted driver also shared that he
experienced a sense of ownership over
kylo Ren but never felt like he had a
full control of him and never shut
himself off to ideas about where the
character would go next this was helpful
going into the rise of Skywalker and
during the making of the film which had
huge responsibilities and following up
the artistic vision of last Jedi
director Rian Johnson and concluding the
decade spanning Skywalker saga with kylo
zark coming to a close in the rise of
Skywalker driver undoubtedly had to get
into a certain frame of mind when
portraying the character what helped him
get there there was the casting crew
whom driver said gave him quote ideas in
the moment and of course Kyla's costume
certainly informed his performance
reforged helmet and all your helmet is
so big check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about Star Wars are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]